[Music]
two fun facts everybody one
there's a national homemade bread
committee and two they have founded
national homemade bread day
back in the 80s to encourage families to
enjoy making bread
together you know who else encourages it
la bonita so here's how they're
celebrating this special day
this month one of my favorite things
about lavonita is
right when you walk into the door you
smell the pandaria
the fresh homemade bread so zyra i'll
take
all of this i'll take all of that okay
hey rocky thank you okay so let's talk
about
you know how homemade bread has to do
with hispanic culture
yes we take we take um homemade bread
very serious here at
bonita our our bread makers are here at
4am getting
the bread ready for you uh fresh and
until you find anything fresh
sweet salty any flavor to your liking
i love it you can smell every flavor i
smell the sweet bread especially but
it's not all about sweet bread right
right right yeah we have rolls we have
cuban bread we have cornbread we have
every type of bread
we also have the ingredients here if you
like to make your own bread at home
awesome yeah so um everything is fresh
um ready for you to try you want to try
some girl you don't have to ask me twice
to try carbs okay
there's like a variety of all types of
different breads we have breads with
filling
yummy ooh look at that oh no see that's
a jalapeno i'm gonna stay away from that
i'm gonna stay away from that
yes but this looks good yeah let's go
here
um that's a cornbread yes what
oh my god and you can always find some
great specials
yes we have our dozen bread um you get
12 pieces for 7.99 we have right now
special for
two uh pieces of bread um
we have all kinds of specials you can
always find specials um at our store
okay and of course obviously all the
time but especially on november 17th
when we're celebrating national homemade
bread day
yes so how can people actually
participate and make their own bread
well if
um if you don't um if you don't have
time you know with work
and the kids at school you can always
find you know the breads homemade breads
you know and if you know if you want to
make it at your own
you can always find the ingredients here
perfect and i see the team working yes
mr wow working overtime over there
well we came in at four in the morning
to make all this great start
needing a dough yes okay so at la bonita
we can celebrate
national homemade bread day on november
17th and every day correct every day yes
yes
i love it all right i'm gonna continue
eating this one and i'm gonna try
i just can i just take this yes yes yeah
but take this entire cart with me
don't worry about it thank you virus
thank you guys
so distracted by the bread i called the
trey cart all right
so there are seven lavanita supermarkets
in vegas valley
click on beneath the markets.com to find
the location nearest you we'll be right
back